طنجه او عروس الشمالي كما يحلو للمغاربه
تسميتها ملتقى البحرين المتوسطي والاطلسي
تتاهب هذه الايام لاستضافه حدث كروي غير
مسبوق فقد وقع عليها الاختيار هذه المره
بجانب العاصمه الرباط لتكون نقطه انطلاق
النسخه ال 19 من كاس العالم للانديه التي
تنظم في المغرب للمره الثالثه بعد نسختي
و2014 اللتين اقيمت في مدن الرباط ومراكش
واكادير
الزائر لمدينه طنجه لن يستمتع فقط بمشاهده
المباريات بل سيكتشف ايضا ما تجود به
المدينه من مواقع سياحيه
ومعالمه تاريخيه مميزه ادعوا كل المشاركين
والزور بمدينه طنجه خارج المغرب او داخل
المغرب بزياره المدينه واكتشاف معالمها
ومتى تخربه من حضاره تاريخيه عريقه جدا
لانه هنا متحيفه هنا بنايه تاريخيه وهنا
شوارع وهنا
ملعب طنجه الكبير ارتدى بدوره ثوب
المونديال التوت تاهبا للحدث الكروي
العالمي ويستضيف الملعب الذي يعرف ايضا
بابن بطوطه ثلاث مباريات بدايه بالمواجهه
افتتاحيه للبطوله بين الاهلي المصري
واوكلاند سيتي نيوزيلاندي وعلى نفس الملعب
سيلاقي الفائز منهما بعد ذلك فريق سياتل
ساوندرس الامريكي على ان تكون اخر
المباريات على ملعب طنجه الكبير في نصف
النهائي وستجمع فلامنجو البرازيلي مع
الفائز من المواجهه العربيه الخالصه بين
الوداد المغربي والهلال السعودي
ان شاء الله باذن الله بالاهلي قدها
الاهلي بلاعيبته بجهازه بادارته بجماهيره
كا احنا كمصدين ناس جايه من كل جميع انحاء
العالم واحنا كمان جايين من ايطاليا وسائل
الاعلام المحليه لاسيما الرياضيه منها
تستعد هي الاخرى لمواكبه المونديالتو من
خلال تغطيه وتقارير خاصه تقرب الجمهور من
كل تفاصيلها هذا الحدث الكروي المنتظر
المسؤوليه وقمنا بمواكبه كل الترتيبات
اللازمه خصوصا الاشغال التي شهدها مركب
ابن بطوطه والملاعب التدابير
المحاديه لله سيكتب ملعب طنجه الكبير
تاريخا جديدا باستضافته لافتتاح النسخه ال
19 من كاس العالم للانديه بين الاهلي
المصري واوكلاند سيتي نيوزيلندي فهل ستحمل
النسخه المغربيه بطلا جديدا ام ستتواصلوا
هيمنه انديه اوروبا وامريكا الجنوبيه على
من التتويج بلقب المونديالو حمزه الراضي
الجزيره طنجه